[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu sou um analista da conversa
eu investigo científicamente como as
pessoas interagem em seus diferentes
papéis tarefas e ações da vida cotidiana
ações muito simples como pedir e dar uma
informação alguém ou explicar alguma
coisa e por vezes ações mais complexas
como convencer alguém de algo ou ter que
dar uma notícia bem ruim
eu olho pra como as pessoas se constroem
e constroem um mundo por meio da fala e
como eu faço isso
eu gravo as com as conversas da vida
cotidiana em vídeo e áudio conversas que
acontecem por aí
no dia a dia da gente então é transcrevo
essas conversas em cada um dos seus
detalhes cada pausa a cada suspiro cada
fala a abandonada ela foi interrompida
fala sobrepostas e daí eu investigo
essas falas em todos os seus detalhes
como ficam essas transcrições mais ou
menos assim é como se a gente rodar se
uma câmera lenta sobre as nossas
conversas colocando uma grande lente de
aumento sobre elas
e daí eu analiso as conversas em todos
esses detalhamentos
isso na verdade é um pouco do que eu
quero fazer com vocês
colocar as nossas conversas cotidianas
sobre uma grande além de aumento e
analisá-las devagarinho
eu quero convidar vocês hoje a explorar
comigo uma fronteira não internacional
muito cotidiana é o espaço internacional
entre uma pergunta e uma resposta
somente eu quero na verdade convidar
vocês a explorar comigo o dna das
interações sociais para investigar essa
fronteira eu quero começar mostrando pra
vocês uma interação em que perguntas
respostas são típicas é uma enquete é
uma enquete que não eu não fiz como
pesquisadora
uma instituição de saúde conduzia para
poder fazer uma avaliação a demográfica
da população que ligava pra lá ela fazia
100 7 por telefone e essas ligações eram
anônimas
o que eu mostro para vocês a seguir são
três perguntas e três respostas assim
qat em que tudo fluiu tudo vai bem as
estão comigo e por favor vejam na tela
o cocan a associados e empresas como
claro pergunta mais informações mas foi
marcada com era uma vez por mês com a
faca love com a para o trigo
representaram souza com plano de saúde
com verna então nada demais aqui a
conversa flui a enquete anda que é uma
maravilha
as pessoas entendem tão bem que a
respondente é capaz de responder às
perguntas do entrevistador a fase antes
mês antes mesmo da entrevista
entrevistadora terminar de fazer essa
pergunta
ou seja tudo vai bem só que numa mesma
interação as coisas podem se complicar a
qualquer momento
eu quero mostrar para vocês a seguir à
próxima pergunta que vem aqui na
continuidade dessa seqüência
vejam a seguir prestem atenção que é
curto
bom agora ocorre agora ópera fatal na al
olhem a pausa que vem depois essa
pergunta não vendo essa é uma pausa
enorme de um ponto 7 segundos que uma
informação bem importante
você sabe quanto tempo leva para alguém
responder alguma pergunta depois que a
pergunta foi feita em média 200
milésimos de segundo só isso
vejam quanto tempo essa mulher precisou
o demorou pra fazer responder essa
pergunta
só que ela ainda assim não respondem
vejam a seguir o que continua
para considerar a oferecer tal nal
o que se vê aqui se vê uma interação que
troca com atrasos mais do que uma vez
repetição reparos né e quando a gente
transcreve a interação com todo esse
detalhamento a gente consegue não apenas
sentir que teve um problema a gente
consegue colocar o dedo onde está o
problema
o problema que está na pergunta e
possivelmente não só no tema da pergunta
mas em como a pergunta foi feita
vejam por exemplo que essa pergunta foi
feita no mesmo formato que a pergunta da
internet a hora a gente sabe que
responder uma enquete uma pessoa
estranha ao telefone sobre eu ter
internet em casa ou não e responder
sobre a minha sexualidade não são ações
equivalentes a falar sobre a sexualidade
demanda que a gente trate esse momento
internacional com um pouco mais de
trabalho que a gente aborde ele de
mansinho e eu quero contar pra vocês que
há profissionais aí fora que sabem fazer
isso abordar alguns assuntos de mansinho
eu passo agora é olhar pra vocês pra uma
das nossas fronteiras especificamente
que é a fronteira da pergunta
nós vamos focar na pergunta aos mudar de
contexto nós vamos para o sus no
atendimento a uma mulher grávida
essa mulher ela está grávida de um bebê
que tem uma malformação é de senso comum
que o uso de álcool cigarro e outras
drogas durante a gravidez pode causar
danos não só a mulher gestante mas
também certamente ao feto
a gente também sabe que uma mulher que
está grávida que faça uso dessas drogas
uso dessas substâncias está sujeita à
avaliação dura a sociedade mas ainda há
gente sabe também seja uma experiência
pessoal ou seja pela literatura que é
muito comum que uma mulher grávida de um
bebê com malformação se sinta culpada
por isso esse médico também sabe vamos
ver a seguir como ele aborda perguntas
que tratam desses assuntos
os jeans
vejam só ele não aborda essas perguntas
como um assunto qualquer
ele introduz cada uma dessas perguntas
com desculpas de perguntar
ele baixa o volume de voz ele podia ser
perguntada se ela fuma não bebe não usa
drogas né mas ele não passasse perguntas
assim ele trata esses assuntos como
potencialmente delicados ou
potencialmente problemáticos e são eu
vou mostrar agora uma outra pergunta que
esse medo de médico também faz que é
potencialmente habilitada também nesse
momento ele está no histórico fazendo um
histórico genético dessa outra gestante
que também está grávida de um bebê com
uma formação
o assunto agora é paternidade já que
estão tratando do histórico genético
vamos lá
veja só a gente essa também não é uma
pergunta qualquer pergunta uma mulher
que já tem outros três filhos e agora
está grávida de um terceiro se esse pai
desse um agora é o pai também das outras
providências também na sociedade que a
gente vive é um tema delicado
eu quero mostrar agora você a gente vai
entrar a mudar um pouquinho de contexto
a gente vai para as consultas
ginecológicas
eu quero mostrar o que mais que a gente
pode descobrir onde está focando a nossa
lente analítica apenas sobre perguntas
ainda a eu nem cheguei ainda há outra
fronteira que são das respostas
eu quero mostrar para vocês o que a
nossa lente analítica consegue ver em
termos de identidades que a gente
pressupõe a pessoa que está à nossa
frente nós vamos agora então por uma
consulta ginecológica
vocês sabem qual é a pergunta mais
freqüente que as mulheres ouvem um
consultório ginecológico
eu tenho certeza que as mulheres aqui
vão se identificar rapidamente com essa
pergunta
prestei atenção essa interação é bem
curtinha pergunta e resposta e acabou
olhe lá
[Música]
ok
tati cuidando direitinho todas as
mulheres sabem o que essa pergunta
significa aqui esse tal tático cuidando
direitinho remete se cuidar para não
levar a verdade uma inflação obviamente
muito importante no que tange o
planejamento familiar
mas o que essa pergunta trazem embutido
em termos de pressupostos a respeito
dessa mulher pensa o seguinte esse
médico está na nese o início da
integração ter duas ou três perguntas só
e já chegou nessa é a primeira vez que
ele atende essa mulher e ele faz essa
pergunta o que tá pressuposto nessa
pergunta nesse formato tático cuidando
direitinho número 1 que essa mulher é
sexualmente ativa nem todas as mulheres
são que essa mulher é fértil
nem todas as mulheres são que essa
mulher não deseja engravidar
ora mulheres que querem ser mães o
daquele determinado momento podem querer
ser mãe e que essa mulher é
heterossexual
se ela precisa se cuidar direitinho para
não engravidar é porque ela tendo
relações sexuais com homens ou seja essa
pergunta ela faz muito mais é uma
pergunta nem problemas não vê nenhum
problema assim olhando só pra ela né
mas ela faz muito mais do que perguntar
e de uma informação
ela pressupõe ela praticamente impõe
identidades para essa mulher
o problema aqui é que é arriscado fazer
uma pergunta assim nesse formato sem
antes fazer outras perguntas pessoas
mulher para essa mulher para saber quem
é a mulher que está à minha frente
mudamos de cenário novamente e agora nós
vamos olhar a nossa outra fronteira a
resposta eu convido vocês agora então
pra olhar para uma outra consulta mas
também do consultório ginecológico
a paciente dessa interação é uma mulher
está sentindo atendida também pela
primeira vez por esse médico e ela
deseja fazer a ligadura de trompas que é
uma laqueadura é uma estabilização
permanente a eu peço que vocês prestem
atenção a reação do médico a uma das
respostas dessa paciente
vamos lá novamente
é o éton mais uma vez às vezes um
pressuposto aqui o marido concorda
well a mas não é esse o meu foco aqui na
verdade a gente já falou de propostas o
que eu quero focar com vocês aqui essa
palavrinha mínima o é que na verdade
vocês podem encontrar muitas gramática
que vocês consultam por aí
vejam que uma palavrinha desse tamanho
de nada faz em termos de quebra de
expectativas ela e zela ok
a quebra de expectativa que esse médico
teve a respeito não apenas dessa mulher
em particular mas de mulheres viúvas em
geral com a expectativa que uma mulher
viúva não têm vida sexual ativa
especialmente uma vida sexual tão ativa
que decide inclusive de uma atualização
permanente
finalmente nós vamos voltar àquela
enquete a falar ainda de respostas
aquela em que acho que eu estava
mostrando vocês lá no início da minha
fala ah e para aquele momento específico
em que houve uma pane internacional de
cinema com ela naquele momento era a
pergunta sobre a heterossexualidade né
você se considera é transexual
só que agora em vez de olhar para a
pergunta nós vamos olhar
postas as entrevistadas e ver novamente
o que as respostas revelam eu vou
mostrar pra vocês respostas a essa
pergunta
vamos ver a seguir o professor então é
só por homens e mulheres
a atração por homens
só o meu marido até entende que é
heterossexual é o interno entendo eu
tenho uma ele é heterossexual
vejam que cada uma dessas respostas faz
muito mais do que simplesmente responder
a perguntas que só pediam por um sim ou
não na essas respostas revelam
entendimento dessas mulheres sobre
questões de gênero e sexualidade por
exemplo que eu sou eu sou uma mulher eu
tenho que gostar de homens elas também
revelam que certas mulheres como elas
certas mulheres encaram atração sexual
não estamos falando de vida sexual
extração né e seus próprios desejos como
é o caso da mulher casada que sente
atração não por homens do plural né
mas apenas por seu homem o seu marido
mas ainda essas respostas também
evidenciam o quanto o próprio
vocabulário sobre sexualidade circula ou
não em certos grupos sociais e isso fica
especialmente evidente quando uma das
perdas dos respondentes relata que ela
tem um primo que é heterossexual
então chego ao final dessa fala e qual o
recado de tudo isso
esqueçam os tais manuais que promete
ensinar a como falar direito
para entender a interação humana como
ela acontece seja para o bem ou para o
mal nós temos excelentes casos e outros
não tão bem sucedidos
nós precisamos primeiro investigar como
as interações acontecem na vida aí fora
no mundo como ele é e aí então quem sabe
escrever um manual mas para investigar
as internações
existe uma ciência específica e qual o
recado número dois o espaço
internacional que a gente viu a
fronteira que eu busquei explorar com
vocês aparentemente tão simples
entre uma pergunta e uma resposta faz
muito mais do que simplesmente das e
pedir uma informação
ela revela muito de quem a gente é de
como a gente entende mundo e o que a
gente pensa sobre as pessoas isso
as relações humanas o espaço entre uma
pergunta e uma resposta na verdade não é
exatamente uma fronteira como se viu
aqui quando ele investigado com uma lupa
uma lupa analítica ele se revela como um
universo praticamente infinito
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]